all right major steps being taken now
the january 6 committee has subpoenaed
trump's former white house lawyer pat
chipoloni patchapoloni is a name
that made headlines on tuesday in part
because the closed captioning
could not handle the name pat chipoloni
at one point it uh the closed captioning
during tuesday's hearing said patsy
bologna
or patsy bologna in other cases so
everybody knows the name pat chipoloni
now patricia poloni has been subpoenaed
to testify uh the guardian reports
january 6 committee subpoenas former
white house counsel patricia poloni
donald trump's former council was a key
witness to some of the ex-president's
most brazen schemes to overturn the 2020
election why do we care about this we
care about this because many of the
claims being made by others who have
testified in front of the january 6
committee are claims about what pat
chipoloni said
and what pat cipoloni told others for
example they're going to charge us with
every crime in the book or something
like that if we do this
if we make this attempt to steal the
election well it would be really great
to get him under oath did he say that
did he believe that what was his uh
assessment of what donald trump was
trying to do
the house select committee has issued a
subpoena
compelling him to testify about at least
three parts of trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 election results
the subpoena marked a dramatic
escalation for the panel and showed its
resolve in seeking to obtain inside
information about how trump sought to
return himself to office
mr chipoloni repeatedly raised legal and
other concerns about trump's activities
on january 6 and the days that proceeded
the committee needs to hear from him on
the record as other former white house
counsels have done in other
congressional investigations
chipoloni was a key witness to some of
trump's most brazen schemes which the
select committee said in its hearings
was part of a sprawling and potentially
unlawful multi-pronged strategy
culminating in the capital attack
chipoloni has information about trump's
push to send fake slates of electors to
congress the subpoena letter said
so is he going to testify
we don't know
every indication so far has been that
folks like chipoloni have no interest in
being put under oath and answering
direct questions about what took place
on january 6 january 5th and the days
approaching it
um he should testify i hope he
cooperates i hope he doesn't take the
steve bannon route and um if we are able
to you know the problem we're having
right now
is you get someone
at every instance
the the sequence is like this
there's the initial sort of framework
for the january 6 committee republicans
say we don't like it we're not
participating okay so then it forces
democrats to say are there any
republicans willing to be on this
committee and adam kinzinger says i'll
do it and liz cheney says i'll do it and
then republicans say well look they they
barely have republicans on the committee
well but that's by your choice
then they get witnesses to testify
uh cassidy hutchinson and others
testifying they make claims under oath
under tremendous legal pressure and a
tremendous societal pressure she now
needs security on and on and on getting
threats
and then in the media
oh well we're willing to have a
different to put put forth our
perspective which contradicts cassidy
hutchinson's okay we'll show up and do
it under oath well they're not willing
to have us yes they are
they said at the end of the hearing
anyone else who has light to shed on
these incidents please come forward we
would like you to testify well where are
they it's now been 48 hours nobody has
been scheduled to testify as of yet
bring them in
and so there's this constant
attempt to say well here's a claim made
under oath here's something someone said
to someone on twitter they they cancel
out so we don't know what the truth is
well no hold on a second the statements
made under oath
attributed to individuals should carry
more weight than the random musings of
someone saying i would show up and say
something different
show up
take the oath and say something
different and then we will evaluate it
let me know on twitter where you can
find me at d pacman do you think any of
these supposed contradictors
are actually going to show up and make
contradictory statements under oath let
me know we'll take a quick break and be
right back
our sponsor javi makes coffee from
concentrate this is so fast and easy and
convenient and i'm looking for fast easy
and convenient right now but i don't
want to sacrifice on flavor the taste is
great it's cost effective you can use it
for hot or cold coffee it comes in
original decaf caramel or caramel please
pick whichever pronunciation you want
french vanilla and mocha it does not
have sugar it does not have dairy you
can add whatever liquid you want water
milk oat milk etc the ingredients are
delicious coffee concentrate and for the
flavored ones natural flavors the coffee
is ethically sourced click the link in
the description
use code pacman for 25 percent off